driving into the heart of Iceland's
volcanic exclusion Zone the town of
grindavik Lies empty it's nearly 4,000
residents ordered to leave in a hurry
after the Earth was shaken by a sudden
inflow of magma on Friday fears of an
eruption remain high even without one
the earthquake swarm has left widescale
damage but this is about much more than
simply repairing the damage that has
been done here there is serious
consideration being given to whether
this place will ever be habitable again
the exclusion Zone includes one of
Iceland's most famous tourist
destinations the Blue Lagoon geothermal
pool efforts are underway to protect it
and a nearby power plant Iceland's
tourism Minister says so far visitors
have not been put off the international
airport is open and it is safe and so we
uh expect that we will have tourists go
to other lagoons which we have uh all
over the country this isn't a first for
Iceland's tourism industry the 2010
eruption of a yukle caused massive
disruption but the publicity sparked
Global interest in Iceland's geology and
helped quadruple foreign visitor numbers
to more than 2 million a year 10% of
them visiting Iceland's lava Center a
short drive from the site of that
devastating eruption it was a huge um
disaster while it lasted U but after
that we we reaped the benefit not only
in tourism but also uh regionally when
it comes to Agriculture and other things
so I think that's kind of one of the
message from icelanders that are used to
this harsh nature like if you treat
nature kindly will treat you kindly back
Nature's kindness might feel in short
supply in and around grindvik right now
but in Iceland people have long learned
to live with and adapt to the powerful
forces that shape their land Harry
forcet Al jazer grindavik Southern
Iceland make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer